a huge breaking news development in the
last few seconds
the former first minister of Scotland
the woman who was at the very heart of
Scotland's government for more than 3
000 days
uh is now uh a police suspect is now
being questioned by police has now been
arrested so this statement released by
police Scotland in the last few minutes
a 52 year old woman has today been
arrested as a suspect in connection with
the ongoing investigation into the
funding and finances of the Scottish
national party uh detectives confirming
that she is in custody she has been
questioned as we speak and they say they
cannot continue uh to comment further
clearly because this is a live police
investigation this is extremely
explosive stuff let's remember this is
an investigation into the smp's funding
into its finances uh centering around uh
what has been a much talked about Ring
fenced funds that were fundraised a
number of years ago to the tune of
around 600 and pounds for the cause of a
second Scottish independence referendum
and there had been some suggestions
around where that money had been spent
within the governing party here in
Scotland the SMP now it has been
probably the most difficult period that
the SMP has endured over the course of
the last number of years we had at
Nicholas sturgeon's husband who was the
long-standing chief executive of the SNP
had been at the Helm of the SNP since
1999 a man called Peter Morrell he was
arrested a number of months ago he spent
12 hours in police custody and was then
released without charge pending further
inquiries that was a humiliating moment
for Nicholas sturgeon and for Peter
model because their house was sealed off
for a period of more than 30 hours there
was a evidence tent erected in their
front lawn the area was swarming with
police officers who were collating
evidence from within that property and
have clearly now been piecing together
their next steps in this investigation
uh let's remember as well that the
treasurer uh the former treasurer of the
SMP a man called Colin Beatty he too was
arrested as part of this long-running
probe into the smp's funding into its
finances and that has been culminated
once again in this major breaking news
this afternoon that Scotland's former
first Minister Nicholas sturgeon is now
in police custody why is this
significant well clearly uh there are
big questions around the funding over
the course of the last number of years
there was leaked footage given to a
Sunday newspaper a number of months ago
of Nicholas sturgeon telling the
national executive committee of the SNP
a number of years ago that they should
not be worried about the finances of
that party uh well clearly that is now a
situation that is under Police
examination those detectives will now
use this period of time to question
Nicholas sturgeon about what she did or
she did not know was going on within the
uh party at that period of time but
let's remember this has huge political
ramifications as well this is a woman
who resigned from Office earlier on this
year it came as a great shock to many
the timing of that and she was clear all
along that she did not know and had no
involvement whatsoever that this uh was
going to be coming down the tracks that
these arrests would be made now clearly
she will be facing those questions over
the course of what will be a 12 hour
that period the maximum period that
police here in Scotland can hold Nikola
sturgeon without bringing any charges or
releasing heart needs to be 12 hours at
that point they will make a decision
about uh whether to release her without
charge pending further inquiries or to
go down a different route but this is a
tricky Point yet again for the SNP there
had been suggestions that this may be
coming this was the next move that the
police would make but clearly this is a
highly sensitive situation uh given the
political ramifications in all of this
as well at the new first Minister Hamza
Yusuf uh will be in a very tricky spot
now because clearly he will not be
commenting further but there will be
questions about uh the how this the the
party has been handled over the course
of the last number of years there was a
suggestion that two few decisions were
made by too few people so Nicola
sturgeon and Peter Morrow clearly were
running the party had control of the
party and there had been a suggestion
for quite some time that uh anyone who
called out any
suggestions of uh questions around the
way that the party was being run while
they were sidelined that was what some
uh within the party had accused Nicholas
sturgeon and Peter muralov but clearly
this is now a significant step forward
within that police investigation it is a
active investigation and people will
need to watch around their commentary
and because now we are moving into uh a
dangerous situation when it comes to
online commentary around this but let's
just recap the police Scotland
confirming 52 year old Nicholas sturgeon
is in custody today facing questions as
a suspect in this long-running
investigation
and Conor of course it is a long-running
investigation as you mentioned Nicola
sturgeon stood down around a lot of
speculation whether she believes she was
due to be arrested that was back in a
few months ago now in February but um
when Peter Murrell her husband as you've
said is was arrested at the time their
property was sealed a full search was
conducted do we know if there's any kind
of Searcher being carried out at their
home right now I I realize that this is
just broken in the last few moments I
just wondered if we have any sense of
activity there too no sense of of
activity today I think the timing is
interesting of this and certainly in
terms of it emerging on a Sunday
afternoon like this but let's remember
the police were swarming that property
uh dozens of detectives inside the home
of Peter model and Nicola sturgeon for
more than 30 hours just a short number
of months ago and within that would have
been that painstaking recovery of any
evidence that may be deemed appropriate
as part of this investigation I think it
would be highly unusual to see police
return to that property unless they have
discovered something or they have
further questions or they will be
looking to recover further items from
that property but let's remember it was
not just the home of Nicholas sturgeon
and Peter Morrow that was rated a number
of months ago the snps headquarters in
Edinburgh was also subject of a police
raid as well number of boxes were
removed from that building Round the
Corner within close proximity to
Scotland's foot of power at holyroods
the Scottish Parliament so that was a
situation that caused a lot of
embarrassment for the SNP let's remember
this is a party who were known for their
discipline under the custodian and
things have well and truly been plunged
into chaos over the last couple of
months